it's time for screen junkies movie
fights today's episode of movie fights
is brought to you by Squarespace
whether you need a domain website or
online store make it with Squarespace
what's up guys last week we were really
really privileged and lucky enough to do
a really cool live movie fights at San
Diego Comic Con in front of about 2500
fans it was awesome it felt really good
it was such a fun night thank you guys
so much for coming out and making that a
really special night for us and we
wanted to share that episode with you
guys today but before we get into it we
wanted to shout out to our friends at
Squarespace for sponsoring today's
episode if you didn't already know
Squarespace makes it super easy to
create your own online identity whether
you're pursuing a side gig or like your
main job or hustle it's never been
easier to sell services or products
online yourself this is an all-in-one
platform they provide 24/7 customer
support there's never anything to
install or patch or upgrade it's super
super easy and make sure you check out
Squarespace come for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch you can go
to Squarespace calm screen junkies to
save 10% on your first purchase of a
website or domain now at the top of this
episode at the show final information
hadn't come out yet about our dear
friend a friend of the community Jon
Schnepp and we wanted to do something
really really special you know just take
a moment to acknowledge him and
acknowledge what his family was
currently going through live at the show
obviously the next day news about Jon
came out but we wanted to give you guys
some you know a little bit of context so
that you weren't like did you guys not
hear so but we hope that the moment we
were able to do with the panel we hope
that Jon heard it we really hope Holly
heard it we hope they're their family
and friends over collider heard it he
was an awesome awesome dude and so this
show is for him thanks Jon and thank you
guys for watching guys we've got an
amazing show for you here's how we want
to kick it off
because screen junkies is about
community you guys are why we're still
here we've got a buddy named Jon Schnepp
and he's going through some serious
serious medical issues he's in critical
condition there's a GoFundMe everyone
sharing it on Twitter if you have a
chance this week please check it out
please donate if you can please share if
you can and what we want to do right now
to kick off the show is to make enough
noise that his family can hear you back
in LA let him hear you right now guys so
we got a lot of fun and games planned
for you but I want to ask you a question
right now are you in the mood for a
fight we have a collection of some of
the premiere movie fighters in the
natural universe and the unnatural
universe Joe what do you think a lot of
things but I just want to get this fight
started what you guys think yeah cuz we
got a barnburner how maybe two fighters
at the height of their powers oh maybe a
couple of iconic fighters bring them up
buddy ladies and gentlemen you know this
gentleman from honest trailers please
put your hands together for Spencer
Gilbert pick a chair pick a chair and
you know this woman as one of the
premier film critics around you know her
from fandom please make some noise for
Clark wolf the wolf so before we get to
the question guys here's how voting did
everybody get a car and everybody got
cards
all right so let's see your Reds gonna
be Spencer screen junkie sides gonna be
Clark wolf okay and we're starting off
with a small question for this one you
guys um what's the best comic book movie
of the decade so far so since 2010 right
I think III do this I don't count yeah
move closer yeah come on Clark okay
let's go mano-a-mano not anymore okay
we're almost at a purge yes I choose
Logan well done sir yeah it's I mean
it's Logan right now all right fine I'll
tell you why in a second yeah Clark yes
well I'll tell you why not in a second
but I went with the Avengers not
infinity war which I do like very much
but the Avengers you pick the bad old
Avengers the bad okay okay Spencer kick
us off buddy all right
we all like candy it's sweet it provides
an instant gratification and we've had a
lot of candy in the MCU over the years a
lot of nice frilly funny jokey things
that really they momentarily satisfy you
but sometimes you want a full meal and
that's why you want Logan you want your
steak you want your spinach you want
your mashed potatoes you want a whole
complete movie and this is complete of a
comic book movie as you'll ever see you
get to see your hero indestructible full
of HDH and just motoring through guys
but you also see him vulnerable you see
him at his lowest in his weakest with
the depression beard and the reading
glasses and stuff like that you get the
x-men tie-ins you get the nods to
continuity but it's also stay a
standalone film that works just as a
complete story on its own it's a
beautiful movie it's got the best
performances of the decade from Hugh
Jackman from Patrick Stewart from Lauda
from it from definitely know everyone
it's it's just a full movie and I just
want to see it over and over again great
okay
so I actually don't disagree with like
95% of that Logan is a great movie I
would argue that Logan is a great movie
that has a superhero in it I do not
think it is the greatest superhero movie
of the last decade I thank you um I'm
saying they vent so look and also when I
said I don't disagree with 95% of what
you just said I include the the Marvel
and candy and all that stuff however I
do think that the Avengers is not an
example of filler and candy the Avengers
did something that I would argue nobody
else had done before which is obviously
bring together all of these characters
and actually make it work this is a
thank you this is this is a movie that
can absolutely stand on its own but it
also moves a bigger franchise forward I
think that this is the first time that
we saw these characters come together
and actually be the best versions of
their superhero self that they could be
you know I I think that it's it's easy
for us now because we get a Captain
America Civil War we get a an infinity
war we get these giant movies all the
time but we can't forget that this was
the first time that this actually worked
so I would argue that when we think of a
traditional superhero movie Avenger the
Avengers is probably the best example
that I can think of of a traditional
superhero movie of the last decades look
it up but all I'm hearing is is over and
over that that it was a team-up that
worked and okay yes they finally managed
to balance enough characters and spin
enough plates but that's not I want more
out of a film what did that give me on a
thematic level it was really just here's
all your action figures together that
was cool the first time but then you now
you see in things like Captain America
Civil War and an infinity war that you
can do that and have themes and real
heart and plot and in that movie they're
fixing a Helicarrier for the whole
second act Loki is look as the world's
dumbest plan they it looks like a TV
show like I'm sorry I know this isn't
gonna win me any fans Joss Whedon is not
a good visual director they're like
three scenes and
movie that look cool the rest looks like
agents of shield it looks like agents of
jail he can write but he can't direct
James Mangold is a director every shot
of that movie is a painting every
performance out of that is deep Andrew
and the Avengers is it's candy and you
look back especially after infinity war
now like you take the beer goggles off
and you look back at the original
Avengers and you're like well ok it's ok
you see now what could have been with
infinity war and it doesn't look as no
but it couldn't have been without the
original Avengers because you have to
build you the reason that Logan why's
the reason ok Logan is a great movie
once again no one's disputing that but
why does Logan pack the punch that it
punches its beat or bad it has it packs
the punch because it has about 18 years
worth of build up that's great this one
yes it's a beautiful send-off to
seventeen years of you Jetsons it
absolutely is and that's why it is the
best Hugh Jackman performance it's
probably the best Hugh Jackman movie but
comic book movie I'm gonna say no listen
at the end of the day
Deadpool Logan they work because they're
subverting known superhero tropes and I
would argue that ten years after Sam
Raimi spider-man via The Avengers uh it
actually plays with these tropes but it
also elevates them and that's why it is
the greatest super they're playing with
tropes but it's Logan is the first
Wolverine movie that's actually been
true to that character every Wolverine
movie in the past we just wanted to
actually sure to actually be the
character we know can curse who can
smoke you can die you know what Spencer
you're right Logan is the best Wolverine
movie of the last decade no all right
guys 30 seconds I agree all right Logan
gives us something that no other comic
book movie has given us and Noah the
comic book movie will because I don't
think they have the guts it gives us
closure it gives us the ending of a
story the stakes of every movie are
undercut by the fact that they've
already announced like seven more
spider-man movies and after he oh yeah
he's gone yeah sure he's gone this is
what we're also not debating infinity
war I just want to remind that to remind
our voting audience that were not
debating infinity war this movie had the
had the cojones and the cojones to kill
Wolverine
so let's have a round of applause for
both of our fighters now in a moment
we're going to ask you to hold up facing
us the side of the card for the fighter
you're pulling for the fighter you
thought one so as we said the red side
is for Spencer the white side is for
Clark all right hold up your cards you
know you know what I think Clark Wolfe
takes the day well fought direwolves
it's a Schmo Town reference how shire
wolves don't you watch all right our
second battle you know her from sju and
being a part of my clique it's Daniel
Radford also corgis also we know her
from corgis and you know this man from
the bottom of my heart
it's kidnap sock
[Applause]
hey how ya what kind of barn burner are
they fighting take a seat you guys take
a seat oh they are fighting a pretty hot
barn burner cuz we talk about this all
the time
oh yeah like you and I will just like
sit in the IHOP parking lot talking
about this um what up I hop yes
try those burgers branding okay
what is the better movie daredevil or
Green Lantern Yeah right this guy knows
this guy knows someone said Seth Rogen's
Green Hornet sorry uh what okay
not in contention how dare Danielle your
choice is I am going for daredevil and
Ken there's only one other choice I was
told to fight for Green Lantern what a
sweet sweet good behind the curtain okay
you're gonna start the clock Danielle
whenever you're ready go for it okay so
obviously I am I'm going off of my phone
which is okay because lord knows ain't
no reception in here Green Lantern was
not just bad it was expensive it had a
budget of 220 million dollars and it
made two hundred million dollars
daredevil a budget of 75 million dollars
made 180 million dollars rounding up
these are all rounding Green Lantern is
Foggs it is so ugly all of that money
was spent on CGI edits bugs
Daredevils director's cut is really good
and pleasant the dumbest thing about
daredevil is a playground scene but at
least that's real people it's real
people being really dumb whereas with
Green Lantern it was like a cartoon
which would have been great if it was
gar tuned because I want to been cheaper
even the star has admitted in many
blazes that it would have been better
for him to have bench
not in the face then to have been in
that movie they wasted Taika Waititi and
the only good thing about Green Lantern
was that Ryan went to Ryan Reynolds
found a wife who can what you got
Daniel Radford is one of these smartest
and funniest people in the room let's
let's give it up for her but that's also
not give it up for her facts because
we're not in a board room for DC or
Warner Brothers anything I don't care
how much these movies make we both know
these movies are horrible that's the
point of this fight we're defending crap
if you're gonna sit down for a superhero
movie you know what I want I want big I
want spectacle I want a director of
James Bond going how did I get to this
movie I don't know we'll figure it out
we've got you've got Ben Affleck a
lifelong daredevil fan who took this
movie for his heart who said I hate this
movie and I want to go be a grumpy
Batman after this Ryan Reynolds said
this is horrible and it inspired him to
make Deadpool something we all loved
which gave us a great scene this is
spectacle do you want to see Ben Affleck
and Jennifer Garner on their first date
or do you want to see Ryan Reynolds
because two hours of Ryan Reynolds
doesn't just make me question things
it gives me answers and I think it is
for a lot of my we're both talking about
two weird-ass couples on their first
date and one of them is fighting in a
playground and one of them is being held
by the other but it's all too weird
couples on the first date like and also
when it comes to when you say that like
oh well we don't want um Ben Affleck Ben
Affleck tried very hard memory well in
the director's cut I will say this is a
real story the director's cut of
daredevil is a really really good solid
movie it is very good
it sets up thank you it sets up a lot of
really fantastic things it is great and
also if daredevil was so shitty
would it have inspired a really good
series I don't think it what
whereas with green lantern everyone it's
like I know thank you don't give me the
thing because no one is a bad round how
to do it you know and no one has we
don't to get about directors cuts you
know Martin Campbell's director's cut
was just him watching Casino Royale
again that's I can't submit that into
evidence here this is about the movies
released in the theater there and and
and look I actually like Ben Affleck I'm
an athletic guy he was brooding he was
bored he he didn't know what to do and
they tried to launch this shared
universe of this new universe that got
some weird call the member Colin Farrell
was in a movie if he was actually in the
movie people don't and wasting to the
YTD there the way careers work you just
you don't know that you're wasting
someone till later you get it you're a
doctor you're a nurse yeah like right
now we're sticking you while you're
fighting for Green Lantern one minute
you guys one man I can agree with and we
should be using but we're talking and as
far as the TV show thing no people saw
daredevil and said we can do this better
they the hell Jordan you've got wrong
you see that you could do daredevil
better and so you did because you were
like you know what I see seeds of a good
thing in this but you see cream and
you're like I'm not doing I'm good look
at the end of I'm straight I'm the drunk
movie fights champion I want a bottle of
whiskey and I want two hours of just fun
spectacular even if it spectacular film
even if Ryan Reynolds says no baby I
don't have money like that is the thing
is like at least with if you didn't like
daredevil it didn't waste a lot of money
and it made money with green lantern it
wasted so much money it made no money it
is bold it is crazy and that is what I'm
want out of a bad good movie sit me down
with no we're not talking about what a
bad good movie is that's a different
fight and I could fight you on that
fight we're now talking about what a bad
good movie is we're times better let's
hear it for both of our fighters
damnit I don't want to win by the way
the only time I ever hear Daniel Radford
curse is when she's movie and it's F
this enough that all right
so let's do the white screen junkie side
for Danielle the red fandom side for Ken
app so go ahead and raise yeah Danielle
radford Danielle you are moving on
Congrats Danielle hello by the way
special announcement stick around
because after our movie fights we're
going to show an honest trailer a
brand-new world premiere on Australia
right Joe star do you guys like being
ready
do you like players do you like the
number one yeah
then stick around regardless of what
your answer is
whoa he just told you what the honest
trailer is gonna be in code it was very
subtle oh my god this fight Oh God are
you guys ready to see two of the like a
top contender a former movie fights
champion this is a collision rocky to
pull oh whoa whoa Lindsey Joe
your first fighter is the fastest speed
round gun in the West coach Andrew
ladies and gentlemen also like the most
dapper movie fighter I didn't know queer
I had a panel man you were good jacket
you look like you're dressed for the
ESPYs this opponent this is probably the
greatest movie fights competitor of all
time his name is Dan Merlin
[Applause]
how what kind of nightmare are they
about to burst our reality into oh man I
mean these are this is too beloved
things clashing whoa better animated
series x-men or Batman I love that noise
I love that noise coy kick us off
brother
I'm the Vengeance I'm the knight I am
Batman
there is only one show that is so good
that it's not been topped in any medium
there is only one animated show that
invented a character that became canon
in the comics and beloved so that it's
referenced in our own video there is
only one show that rewrote the origin to
mr. freeze and retroactively II made
that character not dumb and that is
Batman the Animated Series this show is
25 years old and this 26 years old and
it's just now coming to blu-ray because
we haven't forgotten that her childhood
was way better and they did it right
then this is the most spun off show in
history this show is timeless good and
better than you remember and it's good
for all ages it taught you through
sympathetic villains what it meant to be
a good person while also valuing
intelligence and making Batman a goddamn
detective this show was the first
cartoon to draw
black paper because Batman is that dark
but it was never Schneider dark it's so
good that I feel great about the fact
that Danny Elfman's score is the only
one to rival his rock score and the only
show better than x-men is of course
Batman the Animated Series who Dan
Moreau
I picked x-men I didn't know we were
going right into it okay I picked x-men
the anime series with all due respect to
Batman the Animated Series I watched
both of these when I was a kid
however what sets x-men apart is the
fact Batman the Animated Series was
launched at the height of bat mania
everybody already loved Batman they
loved him in the 60s they loved them in
the comics they loved Michael Keaton
they loved the movies they loved Jack
Nicholson when x-men the animated series
debuted comic book fans liked the x-men
and after x-men the animated series
everyone loved the x-men it didn't take
an already popular character and ride
that wave of popularity it invented the
modern x-men fandom if you like the
x-men movies it's because of x-men the
animated series if you like Logan it's
because of x-men the animated series if
you like anything related to x-men and
culture today it is because x-men the
animated series took the risk of not
treating kids like they were kids and
saying you know what you're grown enough
to understand complicated topics we're
not just gonna give you animated action
we're gonna give you a story we're gonna
give you serialized storytelling and
we're gonna treat you like the adults
that you are when you're kids that you
can't understand this stuff and that you
can look at more than just people
punching each other we're gonna treat
you like people and fans that's what
that show did and that's why it's the
greatest Haley Joe fight it out boys so
I feel like every single thing you just
said about x-men my show did better I
feel like that's a cheap art I just feel
like with the x-men animated series
there were filler episodes there were
times that Jubilee had story time the
only time
people sat down to have a conversation
and x-men was when they were referencing
how bad joel schumacher's batman was
there is a scene in Batman where four
kids are talking about Batman one of
them's name's Joel and they don't let
him talk that's the closest we get to
Jubilee a story time Batman the Animated
Series was so smart that it was meta
before kids could understand what that
was and it's shot treated them like
adults Batman the Animated Series
let there be violence towards children
for the first time because Robin got
smacked around a bit and Nightwing dealt
with some stuff Batman the Animated
Series didn't need to ride in the
coattails because we'd already had the
1660s Adam West's Batman destroy what
Batman was all we had at this point was
Tim Burton's Batman which did help but
this is so much better than Tim Burton's
Batman look at the suit it actually
moves and he's a detective
this didn't ride coattails it superseded
it was an evolution it was so much more
and that's why it hasn't been topped in
26 years I love that mean seriously we
are talking about what is the greater
animated series what makes greatness
greatness is the standard by which all
other iterations are measured and that
is x-men the animated series Batman the
Animated Series is a great version of
the Batman character however there are
people that night Nolan's Batman better
there are people that like the Tim
Burton movies better it is aid it is a
debate among fans what version of Batman
is the best there is no debate among
fans that x-men is the greatest version
of those characters ever made the movies
are based on that standard every piece
of media with the x-men in them is based
on the standard of that animated series
still to this day
Batman is great x-men is the gold
standard for those characters and that's
what makes it better the failure the
failure of other x-men properties is not
on my Batman and Chris Claremont and no
it's on my x-men but Claremont and
Burton I'm pretty sure did some pretty
good stuff a little before the x-men
came out and I'm pretty sure that's
something we weigh it on I'm pretty sure
they based a lot of those things whereas
mine invented new characters invented
new material and when you think of the
Joker I love Jack and ever since Joker
I love youth Ledger's Joker Mark
Hamill's Joker is the goddamn Joker I
don't care who you are
and then they did this little thing
called Batman Beyond that's spun off of
Batman the Animated Series and still
holds up
irrelevant it's spin-off it's a direct
spinoff you also have Batman mask if the
fans hasn't been spun off it
you also have every other property that
began with this 1992 way before its time
piece of perfect cinema that just
happened to be animated were those his
final thoughts do what did I continue
coy you've convinced me that Batman the
Animated Series was a great show and I
didn't need convincing of that it is a
great show but we're talking about which
one is the better show and not only is
it great animation not only is a great
version for kids and for adults of these
characters not only did it surpass every
expectation and take again x-men
characters that outside the curtains a
circle of Marvel Comics we're not a list
characters these were not characters
that were household names this made them
a household name and it actually was a
show that told a story I love the Batman
episodes I love that they're
self-contained you might get a
two-parter here and there x-men had the
courage to do what no other cartoon at
that time did which was to serialize
their storytelling to trust their
audience that they can they can get
complex storytelling and that goes above
and beyond it's not just telling one
great Batman story every 22 minutes it's
telling three or four great x-men
stories across arcs in one coherent
season that isn't just an animated show
that is a great television show 10 you
know what 20 seconds each best animated
series when you think of the art of
x-men are you inspired or do you think
of well that was art when you think of
best animated series do you think of the
beautiful art deco that redefined how we
saw not just Batman but how we saw
cartoons and this was not just one or
two one offs this show had beautiful
arcs that lasted forever we time mr.
Murrow I don't know what the arcs where
that lasted forever in Batman the
Animated Series it's not best animation
in a series it's what's the better
animated series and I'm gonna go with
the one that had superior storytelling
I'm gonna go with the one that was so
confident in treating its characters
that it's still what people want to
judge those characters by today and I'm
gonna go with the one that is still to
this day more relevant because it
introduced what is continuing
these guys a hand so guys here's how
we're gonna vote coy with the sick red
jacket is gonna be your red side mr.
Murrell is gonna be your white screen
junkies side let's see those cards oh
wow dan Moreau takes it give it up for
court you Andrew ladies and gentlemen
that was a hell of a fight they're both
so good
it's Daniel just yelling rigged from the
back cool cool cool hey how what's
coming up oh we got two delightful human
beings and fierce fighters this man you
know I'm from SJ you screen junkies news
and the nerd goat podcast ed Grier and
you know this woman from the schmoes and
all over the place if you're about that
life that Fife life Emma five welcome to
the ring a little question what's the
better franchise Mission Impossible or
fast in the Furious
Edouard ooh you fighting I am fighting
for mission impossible which means a
Fife is fighting for the family that is
correct let's uh let's start with the
left today I'm a five kick us off listen
uh you know when you want to think about
a movie franchise that is truly about
something it is fast and furious the
Mission Impossible films are great we're
looking at two franchises here that are
ultimately big action blockbusters there
are a lot of fun Mission Impossible and
fast the Furious both of them have
gotten better as they've gotten on and
figured out more and more what they are
at the end of the day though what is
Mission Impossible about Mission
Impossible is about Tom Cruise looking
cool okay what's Fast and Furious about
it's about family y'all all right
faster furious is made up of a cast of
incredibly memorable characters all of
whom drive the story forward with their
relationships with one another it is a
movie that made stars out of people like
Vin Diesel out of Dwayne Johnson that
introduced us to gal gadot - played
freakin Wonder Woman okay there is no
doubt in my mind that yes fast and
furious is it a simple concept it's
people driving really fast cars getting
involved in absolutely ridiculous
situations where they have to drive
really really fast cars and there's
explosions and heists and all kinds of
crazy stuff but at the end of the day it
is the connection between those
characters between the family that
drives those films forward and that
makes them more than simply you know
right off summer blockbusters ed Grier
what you got sir this this concept that
is just a vehicle for Tom Cruise to look
cool I will accept that I'll certainly
accept that cuz you know what he looks
damn cool he looks like the American
action hero and I think that's what the
movies are about a lot of ensembles are
ensembles because most of the characters
are kind of whack on their own but when
they team up and start talk about firmly
and and kickflipping their Mustang
knocking guns out of people's hands with
the tail fin whatever you know I just I
feel like these are this is a
multicultural trance
order series you know I mean that we're
talking about it just like yeah boy we
are we all enough we all in the barrio
we all in Dubai we everywhere we just
out here drive a course and it's like I
just I just feel like the Mission
Impossible movies are about something
they're about saving the world they're
not a decent hunt isn't dragging a safe
to the streets decapitating pedestrians
for no reason
yet I mean he's saving the world he's
getting blown from a helicopter onto a
damn train he got the nuclear codes you
got the NOC list the Rope nation is
falling it's all kind of stuff going on
it's like listen I am NOT gonna argue
that Fast and Furious is not a
transportation series but that is
absolutely the strength of it fast and
furious gave a vehicle and
representation to all of these kinds of
you know people from all these different
walks of life all of these different
ethnic backgrounds use bring up the fact
that Tom Cruise is the ultimate American
hero I'm sorry I look around America I
look around this panel room and I don't
just see a bunch of white people
thou shalt not kill
I cannot be killed by diversity I cannot
but here's man y'all can't argue with
the ethnic diversity of fast and furious
also as an employee of NBC Universal I
am contractually obligated to pay that
fast and furious is superior to mission
impossible the top of that let's just
look at some of these box office results
shall we look at the classic nature of
my films hold on these things are very
positive okay the first one is classic
he's old news I agree the first one is
classic the second was classically bad
third when is super awesome and brought
it back sure and now there's been three
more movies and the neck and the next
one seems to be one of the best ones yet
sure wish I could fight using some of
the dopest it's from that one listen I
I'm not gonna disagree the Mission
Impossible films are a lot of fun again
we're looking at two franchises that
both have gotten better as they have
gone on however here is the thing is you
look at Fast and the Furious is you know
international box office results and
they're absolutely astounding mission
Impossibles have also gotten better and
the reason for that is because of
foreign investors that have invest
in Mission Impossible there is a Chinese
company called Alibaba that has invested
if I'm not making this up this is a true
fact - so what the movies are good if
you look at the first Mission Impossible
film - where the Mission Impossible
films are they've gotten so far away
from what they were initially trying to
do with the franchise Fast and the
Furious has been ridiculous since moment
one and lean into that ridiculousness
and the more it embraces that the better
again I would never that's your closing
thought no I would say this nobody's
arguing that the action and either of
these franchises is realistic but what I
personally would like is for it to be
grounded in a a real mission ie savor
the world not stealing stuff from people
not jumping over everything it's so
stupid like like come on we're talking
about a real mission where real a super
endurance character in in Tom Cruise
he's running for three-minute takes to
show you how real it is if he runs for
three-minute take and you see him do
that then when he's getting blown onto a
train or swinging over to Dubai tower
whatever you buy the realism or you buy
into every single stunt and Mission
Impossible so much more than the
ridiculous cartoon that you're
representing time Wow
man can I just say one final thing I
just want to leave you all with a quote
from the great Roman Pearce as played by
Tyrese Gibson in Fast Five in he says
this just went from Mission Impossible
to Mission in-freaking-sanity and I
think that in-freaking-sanity is way
more impressive than I can I get over
joinder no lies okay one rejoinder
Tyrese Gibson drove a Lamborghini on
snow
you know what I think I think we're all
better people for having heard both of
those rejoinders alright so though the
white screen junkies side is from a man
ed Greer the red fandom side is for Miss
Emma Fife go ahead and raise them Oh ed
Grier Oh ed career takes it thank you
guys Emma Fife thank you for playing Ed
Greer see you in the next round we're
moving through it hey Jo did you know
about that Chinese Mission Impossible
conspiracy I just know that the
rejoinders are my favorite Marvel team
can someone go on Snopes and look up
that Chinese Mission Impossible theory
hey how you know what's cool What's Up
boo snacks boy ladies and gentlemen you
know him by another name hashtag
Botanica s' Mike Carlson ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
oh they're not loud enough at all I
agree we can get like one chant going
tonight you guys come on you want some
kind of he wants a chant
[Music]
you just got four different chants yeah
there's like people now people is there
a chat that you want them to chant I
can't hear you from here come here he
wants he wants the word hero chanted
which i think is a pro yeah there we go
[Applause]
and his opponent our personal hero our
editor-in-chief our brave general Roth
Cornett ladies and gentlemen oh this is
going to take beloved things and [ __ ] on
them
who is the best muppet yeah all right
Roth lay it on us who do you have well I
can only speak from my heart and I can
only speak the truth you people so if I
was a pandering person there's a lot of
Muppets that I could go with but I
believe and this is a reference that
three of us in this room will get the
DEF LEPPARD said it best when they said
all I want all I need I have so many
arguments for you but I concede not the
point
so knowing I won I don't know okay folks
here's the thing all right animal is
let's be honest the emboss of toxic
masculinity okay we need a progressive
Muppet in 2018 okay and I'm talking
about gonzo all right this is a blue
alien and this man is so progressive he
is in a polyamorous relationship with a
series of chickens uncommitted he can't
even choose which go he loves don't
judge his lifestyle choice I don't I
applaud his lifestyle choices but when
you think about what the Muppets are to
us as a people and I mean this truly
spiritually its animal because what the
Muppets represent in the world is that
part of us all the parts of us that get
squashed down and repressed after
childhood and you can't feel anything
more and and your life is just a void of
sadness and what Muppet rut
presents Unleashed unremitting passion
more artistry sir I would say artistry
more than animal who says drums are food
his life is his passion he is pure it in
the best possible way he is the Joker if
the Joker was a magnificent King ladies
and gentlemen I I don't identify with
animal I'm a tempered man a reasonable
man some might even say a soulful man
a couple people there would say it folks
I'm talking about his soulful Muppet
name gonzo okay he sings a song around a
campfire about going home and isn't that
sweet
that is incredibly sweet and I I applaud
your mannered nature I really do thank
you I am an ill-mannered woman Oh
passion and fire and I love animal I
truly do I'm not lying to you today he's
in my car y'all I love this Muppets so
damn much on a deep level like in my
soul I love animal and the reason is he
again he represents everything's that
the Muppets are but he's also that thing
if you think about gonzo and a lot of
the rest of them up it's who I adore
they often use like we do humor to evade
emotions to their expression in some
ways you could say that gonzo is an
emotional coward which is maybe why he's
with all those chickens I could not say
that animal is unafraid he can't stop
himself from expressing his every single
feeling folks animal is like hanging out
with a coked-up Andy Dick yes yes no one
wants to do that that would be me what's
more fun to chant
[Music]
got Oh gonzo is also a fun chance it's
not so gonzo gonzo
[Music]
folks into just shouting alright man
that was a lot of fun and it brought
back some great childhood memories and
now one of them will go bye-bye
so thank you okay Roth cornet represents
the white screen junkie side Mike
Carlson is the red fandom side who do
you like
a lot of white Ross Cornette takes it
animal greatest Muppet of all time
gonzo kink shamed for loving chickens
but tannic us botanic us let's uh let's
close out these these opening fights in
in a pretty big way they're how a
redneck yes this woman's one of my
favorite movie fighters you know her
from the schmoes you know her from movie
talk you know her from the Schmo down
you know her from the show up you know
her from the Wonka Schmo which is the
Schmo in all directions parry number off
ladies and gentlemen and you know this
guy from the podcast no deficit you know
him from hyper RPG ladies and gentlemen
the biggest Dragon Ball Z fan in the
room if you are away ladies and
gentlemen remember that one time that
you bench pressed me that was good and
these are guys are going to be fighting
what's the best horror movie of all time
parry what you pick this was one of the
easiest questions that I could have
gotten because there's only one answer
to it and it's Halloween you could look
at it oh I'm sorry I was just getting to
get getting the answers huh what you got
yeah no I I think yeah there you're
right there is one answer in the answer
stands before us and the answer is get
out okay parry kick us off all right so
two very important things going for
Halloween one let's just look at the
movie itself it was super effective the
first time you saw it and that never
changed every single time I watched that
movie
I am chilled to the bone it's pure
simple and that
makes it completely untainted by every
single decade any new piece of
technology you get there is nothing
creepier than seeing the shape lurking
in the shadows looking around the corner
and then the brutality of every single
kill seen the movie has stood the test
of time without a doubt and then if
we're talking about the best horror
movie of all time you also have to
factor in how iconic it is and how it's
affected everything that's come after it
you could look at I mean really it was
one of the first movies to put Steadicam
to use so effectively have you guys seen
that opening shot I mean you really
can't compare it to something like that
and look at how many movies look at how
many filmmakers within the Halloween
franchise and outside of it have tried
to emulate what they pulled off with
that it's a beautifully shot movie the
score you could be anywhere anywhere in
the world and you hear that familiar
score and those particular tones and you
immediately picture Michael Myers you
know you got horror horror as a genre is
super fun because it always a balls with
age because horror at its core is based
off of what we're afraid of
that's why Exorcist was the biggest
horror movie of our time because we
thought people can be but taken over by
demons and which is why get out is going
to be the greatest horror movie for
years to come because we can't seem to
get rid of racism for some reason and
it's always creeping what's fun too is
after I finish get out I can experience
it in real life secondly I'm not scared
of no dude with a knife at this point in
the Halloween franchise we don't know
that Michael Myers is immortal all we
know is he got shot six times 50 cent
got shot nine times I'm more afraid of
50 cent than Michael Myers I you know
and you know anybody would when a Krav
Maga class membership can probably take
out Michael ma he's slow as hell like
that's why they kept getting killed they
kept running fighting like come on like
come on dude and a mask like we got
scary masks I'm more afraid of Slipknot
than anything Michael Myers all right
if someone says they're not afraid of
Michael Myers you know what that person
was probably doing while they were
watching the movie doing that thing
where you look like you're looking at
the movie but you're actually looking at
the corner because it's just too much
you can't fight Michael Myers he is he
is the shape he is this presence and he
has undeniable strength that just about
nobody can go up against and also you
can see my workout this guy I'm bench
pressing 225 pounds squatting 415
deadlift in 500 pounds I could beat up
Michael Myers I could beat up Michael
Myers I got a long list I think about it
every time when I go to sleep what do I
do if somebody comes to me with a knife
and I just imagine I'm just gonna grab
them rip their arms off like a cartoon
character and the Michael Myers like
we're not scared
Michael Myers would not last in today's
America because everyone has ar-15s
they're going to shoot them as a matter
of fact you said that like people can't
fight the one time the movie ends when
they decide you know what how about we
stop running and shoot this dude and
what happened he got shot and he stops
in the movie that is Halloween I'm like
yeah have fun if he the next time you go
visit your white girlfriend's parents
and I'm like yep still scary every time
I will never deny the quality of a movie
like yet get out that is a fantastic
film a fantastic film that came out in
I do deep down believe it's gonna have a
legacy and it's gonna stand the test of
time a lot of other movies just like
Halloween are gonna try to emulate it
right now the proof is in Halloween's
legacy we're only a year out from get
out and I don't see any copycats just
yet I don't see that ripple effect so
once I see that
hey yeah maybe I'll change my room right
now a peek at the best example of that
right now though is Halloween
yeah no Halloween is cool but like it
really it did I'm sorry it does it did
kind of fade with time and there just
isn't that realism that keeps me
grounded in a horror movie because as I
do with a knife you want to know it was
real Halloween too and they shot that
kid when they thought it was Michael
Myers it was like all right I was like
that's
life that's happening everyday trying to
bring down this comedy with some real
[ __ ] but uh you're missing out on the
atmosphere of Halloween I go going back
to the way that movie is shot how every
single thing comes together so so well
to build atmosphere to make you feel
like you were there on Halloween night
in that community with a group of
babysitter's who are taking care of
children it feels so real especially as
someone who grew up doing that and
you're responsible for a child and then
all of a sudden I mean really how many
of you have ever turned a corner and
think that I don't know something on a
coat hanger is a shape that is gonna
come and kill you you know where that
comes from that comes from the shape
Michael Myers and Halloween time that's
here for both fighters you guys you know
I definitely learned how if he would
ward off an attacker rip his arms off
all right so let's do the red side for
our friend Perry the white screen junkie
side for iffy red for Perry White for
iffy raise your cards
[Music]
Perry is moving on iffy thank you sir if
you will be waiting in the hallway to
show you how he can rip someone's arms
up if you with the time to intrude
offensive I could beat that person up
hey how you know what screen junkies
fans hated that time we made movie
fights one on one and they stood oh yeah
so we're not gonna do that for these
semi-finals ladies and gentlemen let's
bring these three semi-finalists up
Clark Woolf Danielle Radford and Dan
Murrow give it up for him
heyhow what are these guys gonna fight
come on Dan
would it be the only properly identified
person up here for like 30 minutes this
is a great comic-con question what
comic-book character who has never been
in a movie would you most want to see a
pier in one so let's start with Clark
and go down the line to hear your
answers all right my answer is Zatanna
okay you got my answer is spider-gwen
okay Dan Moreau my answer is she-hulk
okay let's let's uh let's skip through
these opening arguments and then just
kind of kill each other yeah Clark hit
us off all right so um I first of all I
just love that all three of our answers
are ladies first of all that's like that
that makes me very happy so I know we're
all correct we all win okay No okay so
cetana why I want to see Zatanna is
because I believe in the DCE you believe
it or not I really think I really do and
I think that Justice League dark is a
group of characters that has not been
tapped and I yet on the big screen and I
would love to see or at least recently
and I would love to see them thrive and
I would love to see Zatanna specifically
another reason why I want to see her as
opposed to these other characters is
because the DC EU has Wonder Woman
going for it which I love I love gal
gadot - Wonder Woman she's innocent and
she's a beacon of light and then the DC
EU has Harley Quinn and while I think
that the character of Harley Quinn in
the comics is fascinating and
complicated I was not satisfied with her
portrayal in Suicide Squad okay so yeah
so I think that we need to see a
complicated woman
on screen in the DC EU that is messy
but not a mess which hardly whoo all
right Danielle um I love that you kept
stressing in the DCE you because I think
that spider-gwen is very complicated but
not in like a bad way I think that she
is a very fun character who can bring
some fun and some light and the Marvel
Universe is already filled with fun and
light but the great thing about
spider-gwen is that she's already a
character that you know but you don't
know because she is an alternate
universe Gwen
she's an alternate universe spider
person and her backstory is incredibly
great it's very very fascinating and
very real and I think that now
especially that we have oh my god
spoiler alert infinity Wars
um we're dealing with what might be
different dimensions and different
things we can definitely bring in a
dimension where it's like oh you thought
you was doing a spider-man now you're
doing a spot of Gwen baby and I think
that could be something that's very
we've brought Gwen in to at least I
don't know one of the many spider-man
universes she's available in the comics
and she and we know who she is but now
having her as a spider person I think
just brings a whole nother level to Gwen
and I would love to see her get realized
on the big screen all right Dan Moreau
here's the thing about the she-hulk and
here's to think about the Hulk and why
the Hulk has not worked in his own movie
franchise is once you sit there you wait
for Bruce Banner to turn into the Hulk
and once he turns in the hole he does
pretty much one thing he smashes and
then that's it he can Rican roar he can
do whatever but there's nothing else for
him to do that's why he's kind of now
been folded into the large MCU she hold
gives you all the advantages that Hulk
has but the fact that she is she-hulk is
like the third most impressive thing
about her and what I love about Jennifer
Walters and what I love about what you
can do with she-hulk
is that she could like her defining
characteristic isn't that she's a
superhero her defining characteristic is
that she's a brilliant lawyer she is
really really super smart and she's also
seven feet tall and green and will kick
your ass
that is fun that's what I want to see
folded
to the MCU that's the kind of dimension
that I think we need with characters and
I think that she could add a very unique
flavor to this that you're missing with
the whole because the Hulk is a guy who
gets angry and smashes stuff and that's
about all he can do I want to see that
expanded and I want to see more done
with the Hulk and particularly with
she-hulk I think she can add a lot to
what they already have
all right guys get in there fast and
furious I'm so the thing was she hope is
that she is very very meta and so they
had a a run with her where all she did
was talk about like oh well I can pull
up this issue of this comic book and
fight about it because I'm a lawyer and
it was her dealing with how she would
deal with both being in Jennifer and
being with she hope which is that the
the entity that she was fighting with
I'm tricking you guys I'm actually
literally just fighting for Shiho right
now cuz here's a problem with she-hulk
is the fact that the question is the
character we want to see on the big
screen and we live in a world where the
MC MCU is thriving this is the movies
that we are actually realistically
talking about and if they can't get the
Hulk right and you have somebody like
Mark Ruffalo in that role then how are
we going to bring in she-hulk and do her
justice it's not realistic in the movie
universe that we have right now you
absolutely can because she hooked as a
lawyer and so she's already but the
great the time of being a magician is
the only thing I know about is a time
that's that and she speaks backwards
which is Tyee I can tell you lots of
cool things about Zatanna but at the end
of the day with the reason that I think
she is the chancre she's she speaks
backwards be she smokes pot and her dad
she had a just she has less lore so that
she can actually become fully realized
on the big screen she Danielle if I may
answer up to you arguing for me I also
know I know I know I can already tell
you how we get she-hulk into the MCU on
the big screen because I feel like it is
far past time
that we start integrating the most
popular character from the Netflix
series or arguably but probably the best
show Walters and Murdoch is how you get
she-hulk into the MCU you bring
daredevil in there a law practices there
together you establish your character
you have something that you can hang a
franchise on and I think that would be
also not the question was big screen not
small screen Joe that's how you bring it
up to the big screen is what I'm saying
daredevil as it is on Netflix will never
well not for at least another daredevil
we're arguing she-hulk Wow man we had
people switching characters spidery when
got Infinity Ward all right so since we
have three fighters we're gonna do it
thusly doing hey would you like to
concede your spider-gwen so we have team
Dan team Dan is going to be the white
side the screen junkies side team Clark
is going to be the red side Wow
I mean I think Dan Moreau is going to
the final that was that that was I thank
you everybody thank you
it was like it was like Dan was going up
against Clark and then Daniel Radford
hit Clark with a steel chair that was a
swerve I didn't see any of that coming
hey let's do another semi-final it your
name is Hal I'm about to bring up ed ed
Grier ladies and gentlemen yeah okay
Roth cornet and parry Nemiroff ladies
and gentlemen welcome back to the stage
and these three fine folks will be
fighting something near and dear to my
heart what is the greatest movie
one-liner let's just go down the row
really fast ed what's your one-liner
yippee-ki-yay mother Roth cornet I'll be
back peri may the force be with you I'm
not really gonna give you guys any kind
of a opening argument structure let's
just get into this okay me personally I
think a big thing about best lines is
that there's some sort of subtext to the
line and in this the subtext is I ain't
going nowhere your foreign mother trying
to break in here and steal steal
everybody's stuff do you know that
that's what the line basically says I'm
not going anywhere I'm not scared of you
and I'm not leaving until justice is
served
he's saying a lot with that one line I
don't think every man here Oh Bruce
Willis is so xenophobic but that aside
this is how amazing and iconic that this
one-liner is first of all it defines Who
swartz Nagar is for the rest of his
career because he is the guy that comes
in and delivers the one-liner that does
have that juxtaposition he's this really
scary terminator who says this thing
that because it's such a weird thing to
say and he says it was such sincerity
it's hilarious and then he nails that
again and again and again for the rest
of his career but also is predictive of
what the Terminator franchise is
because it does keep coming back and
back and back and not only that it's a
it's a first choice it's about time
travel it's all baked in there in one
line and it's funny and not only that
how amazing this one-liner is is that
you can quote it by accident
I'll be back what has more subtext and
meaning than may the force be with you
and not just to one character but to
many characters and the force overall
it's also used in so many movies so well
where it could be a game-changer for a
particular character also as someone who
has a tattoo of a movie quote one of the
rules for me with answering this
question was what do I feel passionate
about both on screen in context of the
movie and also something encouraging
that I could apply to my everyday life
that I would actually permanently put it
on myself probably that I probably would
do it yeah my yippee-ki-yay tattoo is
TBD but what I would say is also and if
you forgive the the slight xenophobia
earlier it isn't just that he's from
Germany like your your your robot it's
no I'm super sorry I'm super sorry so so
your murder your murder but from Austria
said this we arguing about characters or
movie lines right now but but wait a
minute and a half left I find they had
to load it they hit the load in the axe
the accent program sometime so basically
what I'm what I'm saying is I love your
line it's very good phobias just gets
worse I shall not be killed by diversity
I said it earlier I said it earlier I
set this whole thing up
now all I'm saying is the 4th of may the
force be with you seems like the epitome
of an empty platitude when you recite
the thoughts and prayers of space no
there there is nothing more than there
is nothing that has more weight and
value than that line which which not
only changes the course for individual
characters but has also changed the
course of the entire franchise it is the
nature versus the dark and the light and
you spread the light by saying may the
force be with you and sharing that with
everybody who got shot in the back by
playing 66 or whatever you know to me it
was with all of them put thoughts of the
prayers it affords for some of them such
a strong one-liner that you don't give
up on good when it stumbles you continue
to spread that message and may the force
be with you is that easy way to spread
that message but the issue for me with
this question is that when you're
thinking about a movie one liner I mean
may the force be with you is very
meaningful and also with you by the way
thank you a movie one liners should be
something that is funny it should be
something that we all say it should be
something that evokes a sense of joy in
us it brings us right back to that
moment in the movie it's relevant to
what you're saying now it has multiple
meanings there's nothing more iconic
there's no one-liner it is a one-liner
of one-liners all right now we can do
the special thing that we have for when
like there's three people okay so for
Edie let's go red for let's go screen
junkies side and for peri just your hand
up in the air okay all right what do we
see I don't know a lot of hands it's I
think it's red it's red Fred all right
everyone with white cards put them down
white cards down white cards down this
one hands and red hands and red I think
it said no cuz hands are hard to come
it's hard it's red and guts it if you
tie a mother so our final is set Dan
Morrow and Greer it's happening right
now
Edie don't go anywhere all right guys
this question has a very special rule
and that rule is you can't argue The
Dark Knight is it cheap using the Dark
Knight as a cheat that's like the power
glove what is the best comic book sequel
of all time dan moreau what you got my
pick is Captain America the Winter
Soldier and gray let me hear it
well my pick is infinity war all right
Dan
kick us off what I think a good sequel
should do is take what happened in the
first movie take your understanding of
the character and take that to a
different place and I would argue even
more than Captain America the First
Avenger that Captain America the Winter
Soldier is the definitive Captain
America movie if you want to know what
Captain America is all about watch that
movie and that's something that very few
sequels do usually the first movie will
set the set the stage give you the
origin and everything and the second
movie is either a rehash of the same
thing or you know debatable what's
better than the first in a second I
think that the Winter Soldier is in
arguably better than the first Captain
America movie and again it established
the storyline it established the stakes
that has taken us to where we are right
now in the MCU including up to and
including infinity war all right ed
Grier you know what
I agree that Winter Soldier is better
than Captain America he spent most of
the most of it on a USO tour kicking
with a bunch of you know Rockettes or
something you know then and they had
like one 10-minute montage I'm throwing
the shield around and all of a sudden
he's a Nazi hunter and it's all great so
I understand the bar was a little bit
low but look infinity war
infinity war is the payoff of the
entirety of the Marvel Universe for ten
years okay
it ties in every single aspect from all
of those disparate movies across all
those disparate genres it brings them
together into one genre a new genre
called the damn superhero movie yet I
mean it's one of the few real superhero
movies I took a friend there who doesn't
read any damn comic books doesn't like
any of these characters they watched the
the raccoon talk to the blond guy
they talked to the they saw the iron guy
with the dude with the funny hands and
they loved it they loved it on just a
pure charm of the Marvel characters
alone on just all those little strings
being pulled even if they didn't
understand all that ten years of history
they still enjoyed that movie find it
out boys here here here's here's my
thing with infinity war and it's a movie
that I enjoyed a lot it is the first
part of the culmination of the first ten
years of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
there's another part to that movie that
is yet to come
there's a lot of great stuff in that but
when I'm looking for a sequel when I'm
looking for what I call the best sequel
of all time it's not just one that has a
lot of great superhero action and stuff
in it and it's not a lot a thing that
ties a bunch of stuff together it's
something that goes beyond just an
action level and it goes to a character
level and I would argue in the genre the
best superhero moment not just in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe or in any
franchise is when Captain America throws
down his shield and he says I'm not
gonna fight you
you're my friend that is the best
superhero moment I think out of any of
those movies it tells you all you need
to know about that character and it's
not the choice that another movie would
have made I like in flirty war but it's
it's part of a movie you have a whole
other movie I certainly agree that
nobody gets beat up like Captain America
nobody he is the best at getting about
one more minute boy so great at it but
what I'm trying to tell you is infinity
war the same thing that cap is a Captain
America getting beat up
that's what Infinity Ward did to the box
office that's what they did to our
psyches um mr. stark I don't feel so
good you not I mean
but you know a lot stuff in that movie
that poles are you know together and has
great action do you know what pull your
heartstrings more than that is when
Bucky turns and he goes Steve and he's
the first one to go and do you know why
they made Bucky the first one to go it's
because of the relationship that they
that they set up between those two guys
and Captain America the Winter Soldier
it's still paying off eight movies down
the line that's how great it was what
they're from Civil War there's payoffs
from black but when they needed to go to
your heartstrings when they needed to
set up how heartbreaking the end of your
movie was they went to the bond between
the two characters and the bedroom
lights all these fights my spider-man
expiring goes more moving than that and
I also think time boys whoo all right
yeah let's hear for both of them all
right we're gonna go read for Edie white
screen junkie side for Dan raise your
cards Dan Merle takes it comic-con movie
fights champion cup on hand for ED Grier
ladies and gentlemen make you cup of
water
[Music]
you